something we do not talk about enough is the colossal scale of male violence
men are the majority of perpetrators of nearly every single violent crime
by a landslide— murder,
SA, stalking,
mass shootings —you name it
and for some of these were talking like over 90% were committed by men
but every year we spend all of our time and energy
debating to what extent we should control women
we call them murderers for their abortions
we threaten them we demonize them
and then you consider the fact that every year
tens of thousands of these women who are seeking abortions
are doing so
because they have been a victim of a man's violent crime against her
and then we have the audacity to label her murderer
to make her take off work and fly to a safe state
(and that's if she's lucky)
at her own expense and if she can't do that
she'll have to risk her health and life
performing non consensual reproductive labor for her government
it is like the crime just repeating itself
the man takes her body and then the government just does the same
and this collective focus on women and their abortions
and what we should do about it is absolutely deliberate
it is a projection of male violence
it is gaslighting on a whole
another level and it's a way to distract from where the pain
and suffering in our communities is actually coming from